what's up everyone so I know I just
released a video that was leaked set
footage of Maria Hill and Nick Fury on
the set of spider-man far from home but
it seems like today is a spider-man far
from home day because a new set footage
video just appeared this time adding
happy hogan so as you can see this time
happy is talking to agent Hill and Nick
Fury and that kind of raises some
questions for starters there's clearly
some sort of collective mission here so
what is the mission is it to just make
sure spider-man doesn't get killed is it
to try and collectively stop Mysterio
together the spider-man work for shield
now does happy work for a shield now
those are questions that we'll just have
to wait to find out but here is the big
thing
Iron Man's not there Tony Stark is not
in any of these leaked videos so I was
talking to a buddy of mine fellow Marvel
YouTube creator wars' too and we were
talking about where in the MCU timeline
does spider-man far from home fallen
nothing has been confirmed and there's
even been rumors that it takes place
before the events of Infinity Ward but
in reality it most likely takes place
after avengers' 4 so there's been a lot
of speculation of which Avengers are
going to die if any of them die in
Avengers 4 it's widely believed that
Tony Stark and Steve Rogers will die
again we don't know we can't know for
sure until we see Avengers sport when it
comes out but so far with everything
that we know about spider-man far from
home plot leaks video leaks set photos
we know that Peter Parker seems to be
mourning something and with all the set
photos and videos that have been leaked
we have not seen Tony Stark and why is
agent Hill and director fury talking to
happy that doesn't really make sense
they would talk to Tony before they
would talk to happy unless Tony's not
there anymore
it makes sense that if Tony died happy
with
after Peter Parker and it's most likely
that happy would play a big part in
Stark Industries if Tony was gone as
well so if Tony died and happy is in
charge of looking after Peter Parker now
and he has a main role at Stark
Industries now it makes sense that he
would be talking to Nick Fury and Maria
hill which is what we see in this video
so does this confirm that iron man dies
in Avengers 4 it is very possible and
most likely why Marvel's trying to keep
such a lid on spider-man far from home
because it'll give away spoilers for
Avengers 4 this is just speculation but
there does seem to be evidence lining up
that Tony Stark dies in Avengers 4 but
what do you all think you think that
these leaked videos point towards Tony
Stark dying in Avengers 4 or do you
think that we just haven't seen him yet
on the set for spider-man far from home
but he will appear eventually let me
know what you think in the comments
below and again the Infinity war blu-ray
giveaway still continues all you have to
do to enter is subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment below with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero thank you so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]